こんにちははじめ社長です皆さんライン使ってますか
そして line スタンプどんなの使ってますかなホットラインスタンプっても本当
にいろんな種類があると思うんですけども僕の一押しは昔動画でも紹介した
名前はするため謎のいいねぬ謎の印ねっていうスタンプがありますちょっと軽くお
さらいしましょう
ああああああああんっ
あ親の家バイバイまず予実浄
山々が暴れてるファンっ
うわぁまずは落ち着けんだあああああもうビールを買うで感じですねあの犬のスタッフ
高めやば確定金ですねいいねのスタンプがあります
そしてなんと
いるの散布台みんなが出ましたーーー
ラックが実はとりあえずちょっと第2弾どんなのか見ていきましょうランちゃんの体の
統制だと汗いいんですけどまぁちょっとカラオケ歌ってますねローソンの見て落ち着い
ている番茶魔法使いのワンちゃん髪の毛生えたマンチャ何キッズしてる万座ラップ服
ワンちゃんご飯食べる番茶三段とばんちゃんなんとも言え表としてますねはぁ丸出し
抹茶敬礼1サプライビッグワンちゃんなんか除いているワンちゃんクラッカーに出て
喜べ抹茶
めちゃくちゃ硬そうなフランさんを食べるばんちゃんそしてこれカードゲームをやって
いるワンちゃんなんかカードゲームつったらカロリーは明後やる気がするんだよ
誰かな誰かに言ってんだよな
46番茶運動するワンちゃん radiko パスランチャ
晴れ
最近だからジコンってかなんかドローンの免許取ったなんかドローンな見るとと
ユーチューバーいたような気がするんだけど誰だったかな
さよなら番サビ中に9番ちゃん次をするワンちゃんも近く1ちゃっ書かれたばあちゃん
誰でドクターワンちゃん
あれ
どこかで白衣着て自
堅牢書ってたユーチューバーがいた気がするなぁ
誰だったかって工事現場ワンちゃん抜き抹茶を the エデルマンちゃくさーい番長
2棟図1 the バレーボール技野球熱々クレイマンさんニンジャマンチャさかまん
ちゃん超品紹介ワンちゃん
あれ
なんかカメラを自分に向けて商品紹介する
なんか職業みたいなのかって気がすんだけどダメだった
頭が編集抹茶
あれ動画編集する職業店もなった気がすんだけど誰だったかな
おやすみワンちゃん歯磨きマンツアー
誰ですから感じ皆ワンちゃん
あれどっかでなハンドスピナーやけに回したいう千葉いたような気がするなぁ
誰だったかまずちょっとほんと使い道がよくわかんでした目だけなんですけど開いた
けど第2弾のバンカースタンプまたまた真逆な都合いいんですけども
謎の印でのアカウント twitter で昔穴場れたんですけどもうちょっとあの人
にこの新しいスタンプが出たよっていうのをちょっと教えてあげようかなって思います
でもタイでは早速バンドと喋っていきましょう
とりあえずでこの子が新しいスターが出てるのは知ってるけど
野本わかんないんで感じ月早速スタンプを送ってみました
さあな沿いにはどういう反応するでしょうか
[音楽]
めっちゃ反応のエンドリア
知ってます異型検査なものですね各席には情報早いなもう吸ってんのか
ちょっと暇に一味んじゃないかってスタンプ終わったんでこれはどうだったのかな
てか最近多いのさん何してんだろうなやっぱフォロワ13572も future ドリ
最近 p っていうのはあなたこの子それなりに交戦してるんですよねよ母綺麗ななん
だかんだ言う4月
買ったって言ってたしすげー7がちゃんと定期的に3日おきぐらいにはンって言って
ます
だが誰かパターンばの半生のまま
ん
魔王バンバンハハマッっ
[音楽]
お前名前変えたってわかってるからな
今度訴追消しすんじゃねーぞ金キャストにはないか移動した
喧嘩ったんやんけあなた帰って来なかったよ帰って来なくなっちゃった
ブサカワなってちょっとこのワンちゃん的にどれが一番好き聞いてみましょう
6個人的な感じにこのゲーでしてますみたいなやつが一番好きなんですよ
おおおおおう
なるほどこれがお勧めらしいですね後ろ姿のやつだ謎の犬もちゃんとなんか
スタンプの擦ってるちょっと感動しましたすごいな溶岩ビーズにやってるなぁ
ちょっと最近元気方についてみようか風紀だったええなぁ
[音楽]
フォア入っクリしたず現在やっ元気がなかっただった
最近の趣味は何ですか催眠の趣味は音楽らしいですね
音楽か最近好きなてなんか39ワンちゃんは音楽にはまってるみたいですねじゃあ最後
に視聴者さんに何か一言
を消えたなんか用としてるっていう
ティオネクタイ米ニューですたい
[音楽]
me
uh
あっはぁ
一本取られますってなんだよ